being able to reimagine yourself beyond
what other people see that is the
toughest task of all but it's also the
most beautiful they said there are no
parts for Latinas here what do you want
to play the maid mm-hmm you you star
you're a star in Mexico why don't you go
back to Mexico as an immigrant you look
for opportunities and so creativity is
part of necessity or necessity as part
of creativity so I said well you know in
this country they don't need more dog
trainers they need somebody who trained
the humans so they can rehabilitate the
dog so I created my own job what's that
believe nation it's Evan my one word is
believe and I believe in you I believe
you have Michael Jordan level talent at
something and I want to see you find it
embrace it and make a difference using
it now this is a still relatively new
series on this channel called somos and
means we are in Spanish now I'm not
Latin myself but I do believe that you
can support one community without
putting another one down so the goal of
this series is to shine a light of
excellence on the Latin community I also
want to give a quick shout-out to Maria
Rodriguez thank you so much for all your
help in this series in sourcing the
clips and your never-ending support I
hope you guys enjoy our let's kick
things off with rule number one embrace
your uniqueness with Mariana Atencio the
day April 10 2014 I was driving to the
studio and I got a call from my parents
or you on the air they asked I
immediately knew something was wrong
what happened I said it's your sister
she's been in a car accident it was as
if my heart stopped my hands gripped to
the steering wheel and I remember
hearing the words it is unlikely she
will ever walk again they say your life
can change in a split second mine did at
that moment my sister went from being my
successful other half only a year part
and age to not being able to move her
legs sit up or get dressed by herself
and this wasn't like summer camp where I
could magically make
better this was terrifying throughout
the course of two years
my sister underwent 15 surgeries and she
spent most of that time in a wheelchair
but that wasn't even the worst of it
the worst was something so painful it's
hard to put into words even now it was
the way people looked at her looked at
us changed people were unable to see a
successful lawyer or a millennial with
sharp wits and a kind heart everywhere
we went I realized that people just saw
poor girl in a wheelchair they were
unable to see anything beyond that after
fighting like a warrior
I can thankfully tell you that today my
sister is walking and has recovered
beyond anyone's expectations thank you
but during that traumatic ordeal I
learned there are differences that
simply suck and it's hard to find
positive in them my sister's not better
off because of what happened but she
taught me you can't let those
differences define you being able to
reimagine yourself beyond what other
people see that is the toughest task of
all but it's also the most beautiful
you see we all come to this world in a
body people with physical or
neurological difficulties
environmentally impacted communities
immigrants boys girls boys who want to
dress as girls girls with veils
women who've been sexually assaulted
athletes who bend their knee as a sign
of protest black white Asian Native
American my sister you or me we all want
what everyone wants to dream and to
achieve but sometimes Society tells us
and we tell ourselves we don't fit
well if you look at my story from being
born somewhere different to belly
dancing in high school to telling
stories you wouldn't normally see on TV
what makes me different is what has made
me stand out and be successful I have
traveled the world and talked to people
from all walks of life and you know what
I've learned the single thing every one
of us has in common is being human so
take a stand to defend your race the
human race let's appeal to it let's be
humanists before and after everything
else we are all quirky and unique and
that is what makes us wonderfully human
rule number two be inspired by
negativity with Salma Hayek what's
interesting is that when you first
started to work that people told you
number one your accent would be a
problem yes they they said its voice
very interesting because they said there
are no parts for Latinas here what do
you want to play the maid mm-hmm you you
start your star in Mexico why don't you
go back to Mexico and they were not
trying to be mean or anything they were
trying to give me good advice that you
will never get a leading role for a
Latina and this is what truly inspired
me and didn't you tell them that Arnold
had an accent oh yeah yeah I don't know
sports maker has an accent and look at
him he's doing all right yeah
rule number three don't chase money with
Elmo del Toro I come from a country
where you didn't make money because you
made movies you lost money because
you're made movies and all of my life
when I approached a new project and I
was 50 50 years old and I've done now I
don't know how many movies has producer
director of la la la and I still have
the same emotion when I go into a
project I go how much am I willing to
lose
to do that image and there's always one
or two images in every project that you
would more than your house sell your car
give everything you have to to make sure
that image comes to save I've heard you
talk about like Pacific Rim it was the
girl with the red she absolutely like
had to make that movie just to see that
it doesn't matter what you go through
doesn't matter if they they give you X
amount of time but you need to always
protect the images that are crucial rule
number four take a shot with Kamiya
Kibeho I initially was not trying to do
music at all I mean I came to the United
States my family came and my parents
made that choice my mom came over to
Miami and her main thing was just like
we don't have money to get you into
college so you're gonna have to get a
scholarship and you're gonna have to
study your butt off and so that was
always my main focus was just I was like
a book nerd that was just like studying
studying studying so I didn't really
think of it as a plausible thing even
though it was always my escape you know
I would always sneak off into my room
when my parents went to Walmart and I
would just like sing but yeah I would
definitely didn't think of it as a
career that was literally just like five
seconds of bravery that changed my life
where I decided to you know try out for
a show we asked Camilla what do you want
for your quinceanera party and she told
me I want you to go with me to an
audition what do you do when you're not
singing I would love to say something
interesting but all I do is think
karaoke and watch like One Direction
videos rule number five respect your
rivals with Rafael Nadal now you know
the Bjorn Borg you know you've heard of
Bjorn Borg and John McEnroe and they
kind of had that rivalry that made both
of them great do you do feel like
Federer and you have that same chemistry
that same dynamic to make one another
greater than if they had not been
playing tennis if they'd not existed you
know no no but
I think every rivalry is completely
different my control board had fantastic
Rio very few time ago and further in
mind we're having a lot of matches last
couple of years now is it's item is
emotion a little bit at the same time no
we are we have a very good relationship
and this is good because we I think we
understand the tennis is really go
without without him or without a guy
like him yeah would your tennis be as
good as it is today but only not you
know really rule number six create your
own job with Cesar Millan as an
immigrant you look for opportunities and
so creativity is part of necessity or
necessity as part of creativity so I
said well you know in this country they
don't need more dog trainers they need
somebody who trained the humans so they
can rehabilitate the dog so I created my
own job because I couldn't compete with
the other guys because I didn't have
papers in the first place so I needed to
open my own job you know and that's when
people start saying you know that guy
has something going on that's that's
when the LA Times came and say you know
Will Smith as your client MBA people are
you crying if a NFL people are you
crying
what would you like to do next and I say
I would like to have my own TV show so
she wrote it down and the the newspaper
came on a Sunday but Monday was a line
of producers outside I wanted to know
what this show is all about it was about
training people and rehabilitating dogs
rule number seven bring something new to
the table with romeo santos romeo santos
isn't just a star he's a global
sensation from Argentina to New York
where the Millennial crooner sold out
Yankee Stadium two nights in a row a
first for Latino artist
[Music]
the video for his hit Indecent Proposal
has over 660 million views that's more
than the most popular Beyonce or Justin
Timberlake videos combined I do go to
lunar we caught up with him before he
took the stage in the Netherlands of all
places I like to just call myself more
as a humble kid from the Bronx style you
know it's blessed to have so many fans
that are so loyal and supportive born
and raised in the Bronx by his
stay-at-home mom and construction worker
father Santos was a shy kid who found
his love for singing at 13 in the church
choir from there he started a boy band
with his cousin and friends and by 21
his band aventura made it big I listen
to bachata and I always felt like
something about that music like wow I
just felt like I was also gonna bring
something new to the table taking
bachata a traditional Dominican music
genre about love and heartache to the
masses today at 33 Romeo knows how to
play to his fans especially the women
who love him they're all my Juliet's
what about the other Romi is that their
do you worry about them getting jealous
well they're not Romeo there's only one
and rule number eight the last one
before a very special bonus clip is push
through with Henny o debes SIA came to
this country to start crossing over
since 2000 2000 2003 and then I quit
spike 2012 I said no more what's changed
though why do you think that's now
finally hopefully you're breaking
through there's something that opens all
the doors here in Hollywood the box
office when I quit I went back to Mexico
so I did this movie called instructions
are included and that movie became the
highest-grossing spanish-language film
ever in the US and worldwide
you
now I've got a really special bonus clip
from Howard Schultz on how to level the
playing field but before that I want to
know what did you enjoy most about this
video this series this series is on the
bubble to be honest with you it hasn't
gotten the traction that we look for
typically in a new series and so I love
the concept I love the vibe I would love
it to continue but I need your support
so let me know if you love to share it
tell your friends if you have feedback
on how to improve it leave it down the
comments below thank you guys so much
for watching I believe in you I hope we
continue to believe in yourself and
whatever your one word is much love I'll
see you soon and enjoy the bonus clip
I have a deep level of sensibility for
people who are living on the other side
of the tracks people who for whatever
reason are labeled and and and and
deeply stigmatized as someone who is not
going to come up in the world and what
I'm trying to do in in the position I
have is to level the playing field and
to do everything we can to make sure
that there's hope and there's
opportunity for everyone regardless of
the color of your skin your gender your
sexual preference or where you were born
or what college you went to and I think
the world would be much much better if
we would embrace humanity embrace
diversity and be much more thoughtful
and respectful of the fact that we have
many more similarities for all of us
than we have differences raise your
standard Apple at the core its core
value is that we believe that people
need passion and not one drop of most
self-worth depends on Europe it's
suppose to mean I don't ever give up I'd
have to be dead or completely
incapacitated hey believe nation if you
want to see my all-time favorite top ten
rows of success I have a very special
secret video for you these are the
individual clips that I have personally
learned the most from and applied to my
life and my business check the link the
description for details